Es ist ein ganz besonderes elektroauto denn sie ist nicht nur ein gewöhnliches elektro sondern zudem auch ein solarauto
der sion gebaut von dem münchner startup sonne motors für mich das elektroauto
2018 ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht doch was kann das solarauto wirklich wie weit ist es in der entwicklung und wie
nachhaltig ist es tatsächlich
alle wichtigen facts zum thema jetzt praktisch science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Ja und vielen dank für den themenvorschlag aus der whatsapp
beziehungsweise sind messenger community
zitats die größten herausforderung bestehen darin den missbrauch von wertvollen und endlichen ressourcen wie zum beispiel erdöl
maßgeblich zu reduzieren denn erdöl ist ein wichtiger fossile nicht erneuerbarer rohstoff unser wichtigstes ziel ist der schutz der umwelt
nur deshalb gibt es so nur motors überhaupt so heißt es auf der offiziellen webseite des münchener start-up
fest steht auf der karosserie des elektroautos sind überall solarpaneele verbaut insgesamt sind es 330
monokristalline silizium-solarzellen aufdach heckklappe motorhaube und an der seite sie liefern
265 watt pro zelle bei einem wirkungsgrad von 24%
75 quadratmeter bilden die zellen
insgesamt und sollen an sonnigen tagen dafür sorgen dass der solarstrom den akku soweit auflädt dass er
zusätzliche 30 kilometer fahren kann wenn wolken am himmel sind sind es immerhin noch 15 kilometer
reichweite die dazu kommt und das ist wirklich eine menge
bisherige entwicklung kam nicht im entferntesten auch solche werte das ganze funktioniert tatsächlich wie auf einem hausdach mit solarmodul
das sonnenlicht selbst elektronen im silizium frei und liefert sogleich strom dieser wird dann in die
wassergekühlte lithium ionen batterie die eine kapazität von 35 bis 45 kilowattstunden hat im
unterboten gespeist wie bei den meisten anderen elektroautos auch wird diese beim bremsvorgang
aufgeladen falls die batterien leer sind gibt es einen haushalts stecker und einen schnell ladestecker
zudem kann es auch von anderen autos strom zapfen aber es kann dann 60 auch selbst als mobile stromspeicher
dienen denn der wagen kann mit der sonnenenergie nicht nur seinen eigenen akku laden sondern theoretisch auch andere
elektroautos zudem soll man sich mit einer app verbinden können falls man doch
einmal liegen bleibt die app zeigt dann an wo der sion oder andere elektroautos stehen die strom benötigen und die anderen leute können dann
starthilfe geben doch die app die soll noch mehr bieten
durch sie können
mitfahrgelegenheiten organisiert werden oder leute aus der nachbarschaft mit denen man sich das auto teilen könnte die können dann gemeinsam darauf
zugreifen und das organisieren und das finde ich persönlich eine richtig gute sache ein auto das ab werk auf carsharing
konzepte getrimmt ist zudem verfügt das solarauto
über ein luftfilter aus moos der feinstaub aus der luft filtert und schaltete eine vierköpfige familie soll das voll betankten auto dann
250 kilometer weit bringen und für familien und den mittelstand
ist dieses auto auch vorrangig gedacht so hat es zwar nicht den luxus eines es doch für ein in dafür ein
instandsetzungs konzept das an sphären angelehnt ist die
fahrer und fahrerinnen können also problemlos selbst gemachte und lizenzfrei
herstellbare ersatzteile nach kaufen und einbauen lassen bisher gibt es aber erst zwei prototypen die im letzten jahr durch europa getourt sind
das ist jetzt auch für deutschland
geplant derzeit steckt so ne motors in der serienentwicklung bis 2019 wollen sie das solarauto auf die straßen bringen bis dahin werden die einzelteile auf
resistenz und leistungsfähigkeit geprüft im sommer also jetzt steht dann ein großer tüv crashtest an
hier wird vor allem spannend was mit den solarzellen passiert sie sind mit einer schicht aus polykarbonat
überzogen und das münchner startup ist
zuversichtlich dass sie unfälle gut überstehen die schicht sorgt außerdem dafür dass das auto ziemlich krass resistent ist die kosten
etwa 16.000 euro ohne batterie die kann man mieten oder kaufen und dann kommen noch einmal 4000 euro dazu mein fazit
bisher klingt das alles so als sei das solarauto ein innovativer schritt hin zu einer tatsächlichen
solar aktuell ektron mobilität die umsetzbar ist teil der im zusammenspiel mit einer entsprechenden infrastruktur
also mit solar straßen und radwegen die ihre eigene energie bereitstellen und wenn dann noch
solarzellen mit einem höheren wirkungsgrad auf den markt kommt wird es extra entspannt schon jetzt hat man am fraunhofer-institut
solarzellen mit einem wirkungsgrad von mehr als 30
entwickelt ja solar energie wird also auch für die mobilität immer
interessanter wenn er kein video dazu zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige abo boxer auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar noch vor
allen anderen täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social and media abonnieren da gibt es
das neueste aus der social media welt und jetzt auch immer mehr videos dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau wie oder vergessen und wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken elektroauto für jeden bis dann
bleibt kann